non-minimalists
how do i let go of my emotional
attachment
to each book i own they all make me feel
something
so it's hard to get rid of them isn't
that fascinating
so making you feel something maybe
shouldn't be the criteria
for holding on to something right they
all might make you feel something but
does that make you feel something good
all my stuff you know the average
american household has 300 000 items in
it when i before i became a minimalist i
was a well organized hoarder i probably
had more than
300 000 items and all that stuff made me
feel something
but most of it made me feel miserable it
made me feel
anxious made me feel overwhelmed
made me feel discontented so they might
make you feel something
but i think maybe what you mean bethany
is they make you feel
good but i think that's not even
criteria
to hold on to something either don't
confuse pleasure
with joy with meaning
with contentment or even with happiness
they might make you feel something but
you might feel
better after you let go there's
something pithy in there you could tweet
sean i do have a pithy answer for you
here
we call these minimal maxims we try to
answer your your lightning round and 140
characters less we put the
text to these minimal maxims in the show
notes so you can copy and share or pick
the answers on social media if you like
by the way you can find all of our
minimal maxims in one place for free
minimal maxims.com my minimal maxim this
week is
clinging is always an inappropriate way
to hold on
clinging is always an inappropriate way
to hold on so
i think what happens when we get
overwhelmed we don't even know where to
start so we don't let go
or we don't let go what do we do we
start clinging
because something is no longer adding
value to us we we're just holding on to
it so tightly
we can't possibly let go and so of
course the first
step in letting go is not just dropping
the thing it's loosening your grip
there are a bunch of ways you can do
that we talk about it in the minimalist
rule book
and we obviously talk about it and
everything that remains but
when i think about letting go
i think about what what's what are the
benefits of letting go it's not just
getting rid of the stuff
because if you just get rid of the books
you go home today get rid of all your
books
a month from now a quarter from now a
year from now you're probably just going
to have another book problem right it's
understanding the benefits
of letting go that's important the why
behind
the what if you understand why these
things are stressing you out and why you
want to let go what are the benefits
maybe it means you have more space maybe
it means less cleaning maybe it means
you're going to start reading
more because you're able to focus on the
few books that you actually
own maybe it means you'll get more joy
from those reference books that you do
keep around
those 20 to 40 to 80 books that you
that you keep around you know i think it
was uh marie kondo
jordan who who said uh 30 books is the
perfect amount of books to own so do you
own the perfect amount of books
yes we have a uh and i had to throw away
the three minimalist books to make it
ah ah throw them away
um just kidding i'm just kidding he
burned them
uh so so no what's fascinating about
this is i can appreciate
the the marie kondo thought process of
minimizing the books but i think that's
an inappropriate number for most
people for me 30 books would probably be
okay now i probably have 40 books and my
wife has 40 books and so we have 80
total
so if you combine those do i have 10 too
many books
well maybe but or maybe i have too few
books
as well maybe what is too
much for me is not enough for you or
vice versa
i don't think there's a perfect number
of books for you to own
in fact there was a period of time in my
early 30s where i owned
zero physical books i did that
intentionally
and so i've brought physical print books
back into my life because sometimes
i find that it's more appropriate to
have a
print book sean let me ask you a podcast
sean you you
you enjoy a kindle you enjoy audio books
as well
but there's also something about print
books so how do you make the distinction
how do you decide what you
want out of a book and what format is
the best format
that's a really good question um usually
uh
reference books i keep um hardback
copies of those
i'm going back to those all the time so
i usually keep a
physical copy of those um
with fiction i was doing the kindle
quite a bit and that was more
convenience thing right you can keep
everything right there you can take it
on the plane
you can pop it out uh use the kindle app
on your phone like you're when you're
waiting in line at the bank or
at a restaurant because everything's
carryout now
um but uh i found myself
and i think you and i have talked about
this going back to physical
books more and more um for fiction too
because of the interaction i can have
with it yeah um
i find myself underlining lines i really
like i
like sure that physical interaction or
marginalia you know writing in the
margins
asking questions uh writing notes to
myself and i feel at that point i'm
really
uh interacting with the author i'm
having a conversation with the author
yeah and that's one of the things that
the books do really well is
even if the author isn't alive david
foster wallace is a prime example of
this he's not here but you can still
have a
exchange of consciousness and by the way
you can have exchange of consciousness
with someone
with whom you were born after they died
and you do that through this medium
called
a book or through writing or the page
right
you